[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في اخبار الساعه من
العربيه
في نيبال و 15 اجنبيه بين الركاب
ايران
ارتفاع وحصله القصف الروسي على مبنى سكني
في مدينه دينيبر الاوكرانيه الى 20 قتيلا
هو اللجنه العسكريه الليبيه تجتمع بحضور
المبعوث الاممي لبحث توحيد الجيش وخروج
المرتزقه
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا قالت وسائل الاعلام
وكانت الطائره التي تحطمت في وقت السابق
72 شخصا بينهم اربعه اربعه من افراد
الطاقه 68 راكبا منهم 15 اجنبيا قبل هذا
افادت السلطات في نيبال 40 من حطام
الطائره التي تحطمت بالقرب من مطار بخار
الدولي
الطائره كانت في طريقها من العاصمه
كاتماندو الى مدينه بخارى وسط النيبال
وحتى افراد الامن والجمهور على المساعده
في جهود الانقاذ
افادت وسائل الاعلام المحليه اوكرانيه بان
عدد قتلى الهجوم الصاروخيه الروسيه في
مدينه ارتفع الى 20 قتيلا في حين وصلت فرق
الانقاذ عملها طوال الليل بحثا عن ناجين
من جانبه
انه قال انه تم انقاذه 38 شخصا ولا يزال
ايضا غير معروف من السكان محاصرين تحت
الانقاذ ياتي ذلك بعد الهجوم الذي وقع
ظهور امس السبت وتسبب ايضا في اصابه ثلاثه
وسبعين شخصا على الاقل
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا هذه الصور المباشره من مدينه
هذا
عدد من الجرحى تحت هذا هذه الانقاض هناك
كما تحدث وسائل الاعلام
الفرق
من سكان المنطقه
افاده بانه تم انقاذه 38 شخصا كما ان هناك
عدد غير معروف حتى اللحظه من سكان هذا
المبنى ما زاله محاصرين تحت الانقاض ذلك
الهجوم مشاهدينا ياتي بعد غارات شنتها
روسيا امس السبت وتسببت ايضا في اصابته 73
شخصا على الاقل
وكما ذكرنا مشاهدينا فقد الضم سكان مدينه
دينيبر الاخرى الى عمال الانقاذ للبحث عن
ناجين محاصرين تحت الانقاذ بعد ان اصاب
صاروخ الروسي مبنى سكريه
[موسيقى]
قال الشركه اوكريني رجل للطاقه الاوكرانيه
انها تواصل العمل على تجاوز تداعيات
استهداف القوات الروسيه لمشاه الطاقه في
الوقت ذاته اعلن وزير الطاقه الاوكراني
هيرمان غالشينكو عن انقطاع التيار
الكهربائي في معظم مناطق اوكرانيه بسبب
عمليات القصف الاخيره مشيرا الى تعزيز
الهجمه الروسيه على مناطق خارقه ولفيفيا
الى جانب العاصمه ما ادى الى فرض قطع
الكهرباء
عمليه تخريبيه ضد صوامع الحبوب في بلده
كاريشينكي ثم توجيه اصابع اتهام الى روسيا
باحداث مجاعه بل باحداث مجاعه في اوكرانيا
وتعطيل صفقه اسطنبول لتصديل الحبوب
مشاهدينا معنا ملكيه والصحفي محمد البابا
معنا في هذه النشره الى اين وصلت عمليات
الانقاذ في دير بروحه اللحظه وكيف تم
استهداف هذا المبنى تحديدا
نعم يعني تم استهداف المبنى السكني في
مدينه
الروسيه التي كانت تحلق فوق الحدود
الاوكرانيه مما ادى حتى هذه اللحظه الى
مقتل 21 شخص واصابه 73 وايضا تعمل فرق
الانقاذ على البحث عن خاصه ان الان يعني
الهدف هو الوصول الى ملجا او الى الملجا
في هذا المبنى حيث من المتوقع ان يكون
هناك بعض الناجين داخل هذا الملجا لان
المبنى رد يعني انهار بشكل كامل بسبب فعل
الصاروخ يعني كان حاولت الدفاع عن الروسيه
عبر بعض وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي التهام
ان هذا الصاروخ كان من الدفاعات الجويه
الاوكرانيه ولكن عن طريق معك همم رئيس
مكتب الرئاسي او مدير مكتب الرئاسه في
اوكرانيا اكد ان يعني الصواريخ الدفاع
الجوي لا تقوم هذه بهذا التمار يعني
قصف هذا المبنى جاء بشكل عشوائي امنه كان
مقصود من قبل قوات الروسيه
يعني وزاره الدفاع الروسيه عاده تقول ان
الصواريخ لها الدقيقه بشكل كبير مما يعني
ان الاهداف هي اهداف مدنيه وايضا يتداول
في وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه ان روسيا
كردستان همم استنفذ جميع بنك اهدافها
العسكريه والان تلجا للضرب يعني الصمود
الكبير للشعب الاوكراني عبر استهداف يعني
ما بين السكنيه احنا راينا يعني قبل ليله
راس السنه هل يعني في 31 من شهر كانون
الاول كان هناك استهداف للعاصمه
الاوكرانيه كيف وثقت ضحايا وكان استيقظه
في الصاروخي يطال فقط الابنيه السكنيه
بالامس ايضا يعني سكت صاروخ على سكني همم
يعني من طابقين في العاصمه الاوكرانيه
وفيروس ايضا في خاركم تتعرض المباني
السكنيه هناك يعني احياء سكنيه بشكل كامل
قد دمرت بشكل كامل يعني ما نراه من
الهاشمه الروسيه خلال الفتره هي استهداف
لمحطات الطاقه التي تؤثر بشكل كبير على
السكان والاهل الاستهدافه السكنيه طيب ااا
على ذكرى استهداف مشاهده الطاقه هناك حديث
ايضا عن انقطاع تام الكهرباء في خاركوف في
لايف في ذا بوليجيا هل مازال التيار
منقطعا
يعني عاده ساعات الصباح الاولى عدد تيار
كهربائي تدريجيا الى اكثر من مدينه لكن في
مدينه خاركوف وضع خاص يعني استهداف محطه
الطاقه الرئيسيه في تلك يعني المقاطعه
بشكل كبير على انقطاع التيار الكهربائي
تمت معالجه المشكله العاصمه الاوكرانيه
كيف الحمد لله يعني عندما تم بالامس
استهداف المحقق الطاقه الصواريخ لن تصدق
اهدافها سقطت بالقرب من محطات الطاقه لذلك
لم تتاثر يعني العاصمه كيف انقطاع كبير
للتيار الكهربائي ولكن هناك عمل كبير الان
في خارطه في نيكل لايف التي تتاثر بشكل
كبير
ايضا
لمعالجه جميع همم يعني همم
ما قامت به الدراجات السابقه
بهذا الشكل لكن كيف كنت معنا الصحفي محمد
البابا تحياتي
مشاهدينا حرب سيارات في اوكرانيا تدفع
الجيوش الاخرى الى التكيف مع استخدامها
نظرا لوفرت هذا النوع من الاسلحه
استخدام المسيرات في حرب اوكرانيا اظهر
الدوره الحاسمه لهذا السلاح
الخبراء تطرقوا لضروره تكيف الجيوش مع
المسيرات سواء في دورها الهجومي او
الدفاعي
المسيرات استخدمت في سوريا ضد داعش وكذلك
في ليبيا
لكن عدد المسيرات ونطاق استخدامها في
اوكرانيا يفوقان اي صراع اخر بحسب مركز
البحوث الامريكي سي ان اي
بلد من مركز سي ان اي اعتبر ان الحرب
اظهرت ان المسيرات الصغيره ضروريه لكل
الوحدات القتاليه
من المهم تجهيز القوات بكميات كبيره جدا
من المسيرات لانها قليله الكلفه
سماحه الحرب في اكرانيا باختبار تقنيات
مضاده للمسيرات خصوصا الامريكيه منها
زودت الولايات المتحده كيف بعدد من
الاسلحه من المدافع الرشاشه وصولا الى
المضادات الجويه
نشر صحيفه ايه الطعم صور تظهر طريقه روسيا
للالتفاف على العقوبات الاقتصاديه الغربيه
عبر بوابات الدول المجاوره المزيد في
التقرير التالي
اقتصاد روسيا في زمن الحرب اظهر قدرتها
السريعه على التاقلمي مع المستجدات رغم
توقعات غربيه بانهيارها سريعا في ظل
عقوبات عزلتها عن العالم
كيفيه حصول ذلك
صحيفه نيويورك الى ان روسيا تحايلت على
منع العديد من البضائع الغربيه من الوصول
اليها
فعلى مدى الاشهر العشره الماضيه برزت
جورجيا قناه اللوجستيه المريحه بين روسيا
والعالم الخارجيه
فما تحتاجه يتدفق اليها عبر الطريق شاحنات
بطيء ومزدحم يمر في جبال القوقاز بحسب صور
نشرتها الصحيفه
كل يومين تعبر قافله من الشاحنات على طول
طريق جبلي سريع من جورجيا نحو الحدود مع
روسيا رحله تبدا اعاده من تركيا وتنتهي في
البلدات والمدن الروسيه حيث يزداد الطلب
على السلع الغربيه
تضاعف حجمه عبور البضائع بين تركيا وروسيا
ثلاث مرات خلال الاشهر السته الاولى من
العام الماضي جرى نقل الكثير منها على
الطرق الجورجيه وفقا لبحث اجره بنك تي بي
سي كابيتال الاستثماري والرائد في جورجيا
تغيير استراتيجيه روسيا لسد حاجاتها
الاساسيه بالحصول على بضائع من دول مجاوره
اخرى مثل ارمينيا واذربيجان ساعد موسكو
على التغلب على العاصفه الاقتصاديه
الناجمه عن حربها على اوكرانيا وفقا
لصحيفه نيورك تايمز التي قالت انه من
المستحيل معرفه مقدار البضائع الاوروبيه
العابره لروسيا والخادعه العقوبات الاتحاد
الاوروبي لكن ظهور جورجياك حلقه من رئيسيه
في التجاره مع موسكو يوصل للضوء على ثغره
المحتمله في سياسه العقوبات الغربيه
روان حمزه العربيه
ابرزتها الحرب في اوكرانيا تدهورت وسائل
الاعلام الالمانيه اخيرا خبر اعتزام وزيره
الدفاع الالمانيه كريستين لامبريت تقديم
في قناتها وانها ابلت المستشارد بقرارها
وذلك نقلا عن اوساط سياسيه وافاد القناه
ان تي في تلفزيونيه بان الوزيره ستعلن
استقالتها غدا الاثنين في الوقت الذي تجري
المانيا مشاورات
بشان امكان تسليم دبابات قتاليه الى الجيش
الاوكراني حيث اعتبر عدد من المراقبين على
الوزيره تواجه صعوبه في ايجاد مكان لها في
عالم القوات المسلحه وانها فهمت انها غير
قادره على انجاز تغيير داخل قوه المسلح
الالمانيه وسير اعلام اشاره ايضا الى ان
الاوساط السياسيه في المانيا يعتبر ان
اصلاح الجيش وشراء معدات الجديده التي
يحتاجها بشده لا يسيران لسرعه الكافيه
وذلك بحسب المراقبين
قال عضو في لجنه الامن القومي والسياسه
الخارجيه في البرلمان الايراني
35 في نهايه مارس المقبل
شهريار حيدري ان مقاتله 35 التي تتسلموها
ايران من روسيا ستضم ايضا معدات عسكريه
تشمل انظمه الدفاعي والصواريخ والمروحيات
وطائرته هليكوبتر هذا وتعد المقاتل
الروسيه 35 من اقوى المقاتلات فهي مجهزه
برادار متقدم لديه القدره على اكتشاف 30
هدفا واجتباك مع ثمانيه اهداف في الوقت
نفسه
تتوالى احكام الاعدام التي يصدرها النظام
الايراني بحق المعارضين الايرانيين بهدف
وقف تحركاتهم مستمره منذ اشهر وكانت اخر
هذه الاعدامات او هذه الاحكام مصدره
القضاء الايراني امس في قضيه المعروفه
باسم بيت اصفهان والحكم على ثلاثه مواطنين
بالاعدام وهم صالح مرحاشمي ومجد يعقوب
وسعيد كاظم في الوقت ذاته اصدره المحكمه
ذاتها حكما بالسجن 26 سنه على لاعب كره
القدم السابق امير النصر ازداني التهامه
بالعضويه في تجمعات غير قانونيه بهدف خلال
بامن البلاد واشارت مصادر الى ان جلسات
محاكمه قضيه بيت اصفهان عقدت في سريه دون
نشر اي معلومات عن حاله المتهمين الذين
تقل له اعمارهم عن اربعين عاما
[موسيقى]
لا تزود الفعل الدوليه المهدده بالاعدام
ايران المساعد السابق لوزير الدفاع
الايراني والمواطن البريطانيه الايراني
علي رضا اكبر
مع شرطه البريطانيه وشدد فرنسا على انه لا
يمكن
القانون الدولي
يحتاجونه
الخارجي
الامريكيه فقد شدت على انها ستحاسب النظام
الايراني
ومتلعب في الدوليه اعدام اكبر مؤكده ان
هذا الانتهاك الايرانيه يدعو للجسم ازازه
حدثته اعدام علي رضا اكبر اذن بعد اتهامه
بالتجسس ونقل معلومات حساسه ليست الاولى
في تاريخ النظام الايراني لكنها اعادت
ملفات اخرى اتهم فيها النظام بل اتهم فيها
عددا من مسؤوليه باتهامات منها التجسس حيث
شغلت هذه القضايا الراي العام الايراني
لفترات طويله وبنظر الى الوراء فان عددا
من المسؤولين الايرانيين المرتبطين
بمجالات حساسه منها العسكريه واجهه
التهامات بالتجسس كما حكم على اغلبهم
بعقوبات تصلوا للاعدام ففي مايو من العام
2016 اعلى نائب الرئيس الايراني السابق
مدينه الانصاري عن اعدام مسؤول الايراني
بتهمه التجسس ايضا دون الكشف عن هويته
مثال اخر مشاهدينا كعلامه سلطات الايرانيه
اعتقال عبد الرضا الدوري
في يوليوم العام 2016 وهو احد ابرز
الخبراء الماليين في المفاوضات النوويه
خلال فتره حسن روحاني وجرى اتهام وصفها
للذي يحمل الجنسيتين الايرانيه والكنديه
بالتجسس لصالح الاستخبارات البريطانيه
هديه والتعاون ايضا مع الولايات المتحده
واذينا بعشر سنوات سجنا
باعدام المواطن الايراني البريطاني بعد
ثلاثه اعوام من اعتقاله وهو ما اثار حمله
تمديد حكوميه واسعه حذرت من ان الاعدام لن
يمرر الكرام اولى الخطوات المتخذه فرض
عقوبات على المدعي العام الايراني رئيس
الوزراء البريطاني ريشيس هناك اعتبر ان
الاعدام عمل قاسم وجبان نفذه نظام همجي لا
يحترم حقوق الانسان في ما اعتبره وزير
الخارجيه انا اعدام اكبر في ايران يستحق
الادانه بكل العبارات
ادانه بدا يتساءل الكثيرون عن شكل تنفيذها
من قبل الحكومه البريطانيه حيث دعى نواب
الى ضروره اخذ موقف اكثر حزما لحمايه
المواطنين البريطانيين مزدوجه الجنسيه
فيما دعى نواب الى ضروره اتخاذ خطوات تعكس
مدى الاستياء من التهديدات الايرانيه التي
طالت مقيمين في بريطانيا وهو مدفع
بريطانيا الى دراسه قرار ادراج الحرس
الثوري الايراني على قائمه الارهاب
قد يصبح اكثر الحاحا مع تنفيذها عمليه
الاعدام بحق اكبر
والعشرات من الايرانيين الذين ينتظرون
تنفيذ حكم الاعدام بحقهم بسبب مشاركتهم في
المظاهرات وهو ما جعل توقيت اعدام اكبر
يزيد من نبره التمديد البريطانيه في
تحركات الايرانيه هنا من لندن عروب عبد
الحق العربيه
في هذه النشره من الواضح ان النظام
الايراني
هل تكون العله في النظام نفسه ام في مدى
جديه هذه الغرفه الغربيه بالطبع يعني هو
طبيعه النظام النظام قمعي استبدالي منذ ان
استلم السلطان عام 1979 بدا همم اعدام همم
التيارات التي عرضت في البدايه نظام ولايه
الفقيه والجمهور الاسلاميه كال- همم
الليبراليين واليسارين وغيرها ثم همم وصلت
تصفيات الى اقرب مقر بانظام في وزير
الخارجيه قطب واشخاص اخرين كانوا من ضمن
النظام ايضا ثم بعد ذلك همم في الثمانينات
كانت موجه من الاعدامات ضد السجناء
السياسيين وازدادت هذه الوتيره خلال
السنوات الاخيره
سبب زياده الاحتجاجات والرفض الشعبي
وفقدان النظام مشروعيته الداخليه الامر
الاخر هو همم ذات بعد خارجي ويتعلق بمسار
المفاوضات النوويه في السابق كان النظام
همم يعني يقتل ويقمع ولكن تاتي الدول
الغربيه وتتفاوض معه وتعقد الصفقات
التجاريه والاقتصاديه همم الاتفاق النووي
وغيره من الاتفاقيات الثنائيه كانت تغذي
خزينه النظام ما ادى الى همم استطاعته
بتمويل
التوسع في همم دول همم هذه الدول تهتم
بمصالحها اكثر من مساله حقوق الانسان التي
تنتهي بالطبع لكن الان حدثها هناك تضارب
في هذه المصالح النظام الايراني وصل به
الامر الى ان يتدخل في شؤون الاوروبيه
يتدخل في الحرب الاوكرانيه بشكل مباشر هذا
منعكس سلبا همم سياسه
الابتزاز يعني سواء الابتزاز في النووي او
في الملفات الاخرى ايضا اوصل المفاوضات
الى طريق مسدود مؤخرا يعني راينا تغير همم
نوعا ما غير مسبوق في سياسه الخارجيه
الاوروبيه تجاه ايران وهذا ما دفع بالنظام
الايراني ان يرسل رسائل همم الى المجتمع
الدولي لانه لن يكترث بهذه الضغوط ويستمر
في الاعدامات وفي القمه وفي الحقيقه هذا
هو النهج الوحيد
ان هي عاجزه عن همم عن معاقبه النظام
الايراني بشكل فعليه يبدو انها لا تمتلك
سوى العقوبات او مثلا همم عقوبات رمزيه
حتى مثل سحب بريطانيا السفيرها من ايران
مؤقتا
ليست عاجزه ولكنها لا تريد ان تذهب الامور
باتجاه انهيار المفاجاه
ومره اخرى تتحدث عن عدم وجود همم بديل
جاهز لكن باستطاعتها لو ارادت اتخاذ خطوات
عمليه غير همم انا التمديد والادانه همم
وقف العلاقات التجاريه والاقتصاديه مع
النظام الايراني وقف تمثيل ايران في الان
هناك في الخارج
المعرضون الايرانيون والعديد من المنظمات
تدفع باتجاه طرد سفراء النظام الايراني من
الدول الاوروبيه خاصه الدول التي ارتكبت
فيها ايران اعمالا ارهابيه وايضا منظمات
النظام من المجتمع الدولي لان هذا النظام
سواء هذه اللغه عندها فقط يرضى
معنا في الاستوديو السيد صالح حميد
الايراني
محمد جعفر منتظري ساهم في التنظيم القضائي
داخل الحرس الثوري الايراني
اعتبر اعدامات الثمانينات مفخره للقضاء
الايرانيه
انتقد وزير الاتصالات لفشله في السيطره
على الفضاء الالكتروني خلال الاحتجاجات
[موسيقى]
الرئيس الاسبق لمحكمه العدل الاداري
والمحكمه الدينيه
يقف وراء اصدار احكام الاعدام ضد المحتجين
والمصادقه عليها
[موسيقى]
المجتمع الدولي يقول ان منتظر يقود
محاكمات سوريه غير متوافقه مع القوانين
في ابريل 2016 عينه منتظري مدعيا عاما
لايران
في ديسمبر 2022
واشنطن تفرض عقوبات على منتظر لدوره في
الاعدامات
[موسيقى]
في يناير
2023 بريطانيا تفرض عقوبات على منتظر
لدوره في اعدام علي اكبري
طانيه اعاده النظر في دعمها للاتفاق
النووي الايراني بعد اعدام النظام
الايراني عريضه اكبر الذي يحمل الجنسيتين
بريطانيا
وقال مصدر حكومي بريطاني للصحيفه انه خلال
فتره المفاوضات مع ايران تغير المشهد
والمعطيات بشكل كامل بسبب السلوك النظام
الايراني مشيرا الى ان جميع الخيارات قيد
المراجعه قبل ذلك اعلنت بريطانيا استدعاء
السفيرها من ايران مؤقتا للتشاور ردانا
على اعدام اكبر الذي شغل في السابق نائب
وزير الدفاع الايراني والتهمه بالتجسس
لصالح بريطانيا
مستمر مشاهدينا وفيها بعض الفاصل في
تظاهره تعده هي الاكبر عشرات الالاف
تظاهرون في الوسيط تل ابيب ضد حكومه
نتنياه اليمنيه
[موسيقى]
يعني زوجات الدكتور دخل في مواجهه صريحه
وموالنه مع كل محاولات ادلجه الاسلام او
التوظيف النفسي للاسلام
في اي حملات ضده اللي ولع الدنيا كتاب
صغير قد كده اسمه نقد الخطاب الديني وكنت
انا من انصار فكره حسن حنفي بانه تناقشه
هذه المسائل
الخوف موجود في كل مكان
[موسيقى]
حامد ابو زين الجمعه التاسعه على شاشه
العربيه
خطوات نمضيها بكل ثقه
الى اهدافنا
سواء كنا لاعبين او محللين او مشجعين
يتخط الذين نعرفه عالم اكثر شفافيه متوجا
بالمجد تعيش فيه اجمل اللحظاتنا قد ننجح
وقد نتعذب
لكننا لا نستسلم
نحن واثقون من انفسنا من المضيق دبي الكره
السعوديه في المراه مع بدايه من الثلاثاء
الى الخميس منتصف الليل على شاشه العربيه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد
رئيسيه امس السبت احتجاجا على خطط رئيس
الوزراء الاصلاح
لتقويه الحكم الديمقراطي
[موسيقى]
اليمين على النظام السياسي والقضائي في
اسرائيل يسعى نتنياهو الى تمرير مشروع
قانون لتوسيع لجنه اختيار قضاه المحكمه
العليا على ان يكون سبعه منهم من تعيين
الحكومه الامر الذي يعطيها اغلبيه تلقائيه
مطلقه وهو وصفه المتظاهرون بالانقلاب
المظاهر المناهضه لحكومه تحت عنوان نقاتل
من اجل الديمقراطيه
انتشار واسع للشرطه الاسرائيليه في ظل
تعليمات من وزير الامن القومي المتطرف
اعتمر بني كبير بالتعامل بقوه مع متظاهرين
اليسار والمعارضه وقد يكون النزول الى
الشارع بدايه مواجهه بين المعسكريين
وستتحذيرا بعض الاسرائيليين من خطر نشوب
حرب اهليه
لا ناكل غاصب من تل ابيب العربيه
[موسيقى]
للدور الاول للانتخابات التشريعيه ويقدم
ارسنال الانتخابيه للدور الثاني فضلا عن
المؤشرات المتعلقه بالاستعدادات للدوري
الثاني ومن المقرر ان تصادق الهيئه على
نتائج الدور الاول ورزنامه الدور الثاني
وفق ما ورد على لسان ناطق الرسمي باسم
الهيئه محمد الدليلي
المصري لها
اعلان الحكومه النيل الازرق في السودان عن
اكمال كافه الترتيبات لزياره رئيس المجلس
عبد الفتاح البرهان الاقليمي المقرر
المقرره اليوم
بعد اعمال عن في شهدتها محافظه ود الماحي
ما ادى الى مقتل نحو سته اشخاص واصابه 13
اخرين
باسم القوات المسلحه السودانيه العميد
نبيل عبد الله العربيه قال ان زياره
البرهان الاقليم اليوم في مصالحه بين
القبائل والمكونات
اكد للمتحدث باسم الرئاسه التركيه ابراهيم
قال ان شن عمليه عسكريه بريه في سوريا
ممكن في اي وقت وقال قال ان بلاده تواصل
دعم العمليه السياسيه التي بدات نهايه
ديسمبر مع لقاء وزيري الدفاع تركي والسوري
في موسكو لكن عشان عمليه البريه يبقى ممكن
في اي وقت بناء على مستوى التحديثات
الوارده
نشاطنا مستمر مشاهدينا وفيها بعض الفاصل
قبيله جلسه مجلس الامن وزير الخارجيه
اليمنيه مواقف دوريه اكثر الصرامه تجاه
الحوثيين
انت شالو 40
بين الركاب
طيران
اللجنه العسكريه الليبيه تجتمع بحضور
المبعوث الامم لبحث توحيد الجيش وخروج
المرتزقه
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد جدد وزير
خارجيه اليمني احمد عوض بمباركه تحضيرا من
الخاطر الذي يشكله الحوثيون على اليمن هو
المنطقه متهمه اياهم بانهم ليسوا شركاء
السلام وقال بمبارك خلال لقاء مع القائد
باعمال السفاره الروسيه لدى اليمن
الحديده في البحر الاحمر واعت ذلك في
الوقت الذي يستعد مجلس الامن الدولي لعقد
جلسه مغلقه سيستمع خلالها لاحاطه من
المبعوث الاميه حول اخر تطورات المساء
تجديد الهدنه القضيه وتوسيعها
كشف ريتشار سوبر المحامي الخاص للرئيس
الامريكي تفاصيل الوصول للوثائق السريه في
منزل الرئيس الامريكي حيث قال انه تم
اكتشافه 5 اوراق الاضافيه بالخمسه اوراق
اضافيه اذا بعلامات تفيده بالسريه بمنزل
الرئيس وانه جرى تسليمها على الفور الى
مسؤولي وزاره العدل وفي التفاصيل انه سافر
مسترد بعلامات تفيد بالسريه الى وزاره
العدل تم العثور عليه هناك في وقت سابق
الا انه بينما كان يقوم بنقل المستند الى
مسؤوله وزاره العدل تم اكتشافه 5 اوراق
اضافيه بعلامات تصنيف سري بين المواد
الموجوده مع ليصبح المجموع سته اوراق وقد
استحود عليها مسؤول وزاره العدل المرافقين
اعلنت وزيره الخزانه الامريكيه جنتيلن ان
الولايات المتحده قد تحتاج الى اتخاذ
اجراءات الاستثنائيه لتجنيب تخلفها عن سبب
الدين الامريكي باعتبارا من الاسبوع
المقبل حيث يتوقع ان تصل الى سقف لسدانه
الحالي المحدد
واوضحت في رساله الى الكونجرس ان الفشل في
تلبيه واجبات الحكومه سلحق ضارا لا يعوض
بالاقتصاد الامريكي وسبل يعيش الامريكيين
كاف والاستقرار
الى انه من المتوقع ان تصل الولايات
المتحده الى سقف المديريه الخميس المقبل
والامطار والثلوج ما اثار بخاوف من حدوث
فيضانات وتسببت الامطار في انقطاع التيار
الكهربائي واسفرت عن مختلفه لا يقل عن
تسعه 10 شخصا
[موسيقى]
قررت الحكومه البيروفيه اعلان حاله طوارئ
وسط استمار التظاهرات المطالبه استقاله
رئيسه البلاد واردت في حياه 42 شخصا على
الاقل مده ديسمبر الماضي
للجيش التدخل للحفاظ على النظام هذا
واعتبر الرئيس دينارتي عن سقوط عشرات
الضحايا في احتجاجات عامه انحاء البلاد في
الاسابيع الاخيره
الان مشاهدينا الاخبار الاقتصاد مع ناصر
شكرا احمد اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام اذا
المتابع حركه مؤشر السوق السعودي الذي بدا
تداولات اليوم على بعض الارتفاعات بثلاثه
اعشار النقطه المئويه ومازال محافظا على
هذه المكاسب ليبقى عند اعلى مستوياته منذ
مطلع شهر ديسمبر التي كان خلالها يتحرك
بنطاقه عرضي طوال تلك الفتره بعد
الانخفاضات التي شهدناها طوال شهر نوفمبر
هذا بالنسبه لمؤشر السوق السعوديه الاسهم
الاكثر نشاطا تتركز على مصرف الراجحي من
الحد اكثر من 110 ريال من السيوله
المتداوله على مصرف الراجحي حتى هذه
اللحظه والسهم الاكثر نشاطه من حيث القيمه
الراجحي كانت قد اعلنت عن توصيه مجلس
الاداره بتوزيع ارباح تصل الى ريال وربع
الريال للسهم عن العام 20 22 لا ننسى بانه
العام الماضي في النصف الاول كان هناك
توزيعات لاسه ارحب منحه في اضطرار طبعا
الراجحي لزياده راس ماله ورسملت بعد
الارباح الموقات همم في همم طبعا همم
الكفايه راس المال في ظل التوسع الكبير
والسريع جدا في محفظته الاقراضيه هذا
الامر نفسه ايضا شاهدنا البنك الاهلي
نهايه الاسبوع الماضي يقوم ايضا بتوصيه
بزياده راس ماله من 45 مليار ريال تقريبا
الى 60 مليار ريال وهي همم
نزعه وتوجه همم عدد كبير من المحللين
يتوقعون بان البنوك ستضطر للمزيد من زياده
راس المال همم للمحافظه على مؤشرات كفايه
الراس المال هذه السنه في ظل وسعهم في
الاقراض الراجحي الاكثر تداوله من حيث
القيمه مكاسب بواحد في المئه في امريكانا
للمطاعم على تراجع الى ثلاث ريالات 46 هل
لا لا وها هو الاهلي مشاهدينا مكاسب بواحد
في المئه الى ما فوق ال 50 ريال بعض
التراجعات طفيفه على سابك بربع النقطه
المئويه اكثر حده على معادن بواحد ونصف
النقطه المئويه كنا قد شاهدنا عدد من
الاتفاقيات والشراكات بين معادن وبعض
الشركات الاخرى تحديدا بارك لتاسيس عدد من
الشركات همم للاستكشاف المعادن داخل
المملكه وايضا شراكه مع صندوق الاستثمارات
العامه للاستثمار الدوليه في الاصول
التعدينيه هذا بالنسبه لمعادن الاسهم
الاتصالات بعض المكاسب عليها لكن زين
تخالف الاتجاه العام نزولا باربعه اشار
النقطه المئويه ارامكو 32 ريال
وعشر هلالات هذه كانت مشاهدينا وقفتنا مع
جلسه التداول السعوديه انا عود الان من
جديد الى استديوهاتنا في الرياض مع زميله
احمد
مشاهدينا بالعوده مره الى ملف السوداني
وفعاليات مهرجان الرمايه في اقليم النيل
الازرق بحضور رئيس مجلس السيد عبد الفتاح
برهان
عربيه محمد عثمان
بدايه اهداف هذه الزياره والى اين وصلت
حتى اللحظه
سياسي ما هو عسكري هو مهرجان الرمايه في
نسخته السابعه والخمسين بمشاركه كافه
الوحدات العسكريه من سلاح المدفعيه
والفلاحه المهندسين وكذلك قوات الدعم
السريع والقوات الجويه والقوات البحريه
وايضا منظومه الدفاعات الصناعيه وبالتالي
هي مشاركه واسعه لكافه الوحدات العسكريه
في هذا المهرجان الذي يقام عام بعد عام
للوصول الى مستوى تدريبي بحسب ما تحدث
الينا الناطق الرسمي باسم القوات المسلحه
هذا الامر ايضا ياتي في ظل التوترات امنيه
كانت تشهدها هذا هذه المنطقه ويشهدها هذا
الاقليم تحدث اليها الناطق الرسمي باسم
القوات المسلحه بان اقامه هذا المهرجان في
هذا التوقيت تحديدا فيه رساله الى مشاركه
القوات المسلحه
في راعي بين المكونات
القبائل اشتعلت بينها الفتنه
الماضي من العامه الماضي وادى الى مقتل
كثير من المواطنين ونزوح العشرات بل
المئات الى مناطق قريبه من هذا الاقليم
وبالتالي هنالك الرسائل تريد ان ترسلها
القوات المسلحه والجيش السوداني من خلال
اقامه هذا المهرجان في هذا التوقيت تحديدا
ايضا برنامج عمل رئيس مجلس سياده القائد
العام
هذا
المسلسل همم
سيحضر نهار هذا اليوم مصالحاتها قبليه بين
المكونات الاجتماعيه التي شهد الصراعا
فيها فتره الماضيه الان احمد ارى من على
البعد الان يتحدث السيد رئيس مجلس هذا صعد
على المنصه لمخاطبه
العسكري في المشاهدين ان استمع الى كلمه
رئيس مجلس السياده عبد الفتاح البرهان بعد
زيارته بعد وصوله الى ولايه النيل الازرق
لمتابعه هذا المهرجان مهرجان الرمايه
وايضا لحضور جلسه صلح بين قبائل متناحره
خلال الاشهر الماضيه تتابع اذا كلمه رئيس
مجلس السياده عبد الفتاح البرهاني
اعوذ بالله من الشيطان الرجيم
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
اعوذ بالله من الشيطان الرجيم بسم الله
الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد لله
الذي بنعمته تتم الصالحات
والصلاه والسلام على سيدنا محمد وعلى اله
وصحبه وسلم
حضور جميعا
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
اولا
تحيه واجبه لاهلنا
تحيه واجبه
لاهلنا في اقليم مدينه الازرق
تحيه
انتم اهل الله و تستحقونها جميعا
نحييكم
باسم القوات المسلحه انتم
ظللتم دوما
حاضر امين لهذه المؤسسه
مؤسسه السودان الاولى
شكرا لكم شكرا لما قدمتموه من كرم اصيل
ينمو عن اصاله
عن كل افرادنا المتواجدين في هذا المكان
وفي كل مكان اخر من السودان
تحيه
لكل قواتنا المسلحه وقواتنا النظاميه
المرابطين في صور السودان
يدافعون عنه ويحمون صغوره
تحيه
للقائمين على امر هذا المهرجان تحيه خاصه
للفرق الفائزه
وللمتفوقين
القادمه 58
نكون قد استكملنا بناء ونهضه قوات المسلحه
او على الاقل وضعنا طريق وضعنا اقدامنا في
الطريق الصحيح لكم
التقدير جميعكم اولا نحن في هذا المقام
يجب ان نذكر بان اقامه المهرجان في هذا
المكان كان يواجهه تحدي تحدي كبير
[موسيقى]
وهم البنيان بتاع السودان واحده من
الركايزه الممالك
المملكه السمان مملكه قتله مملكه الفوز
كلها المنطقه قديمه مالك قديمه ظلت ترعى
السودان وظلت هي حاضنه لكل شعب السودان
نحنا كلنا كسودانين حزينه كثيرا لما جرى
من احداث وحزين ما كثيرا
للتناحر والتباغض الذي دب بين ابناء الوطن
الواحد وبين ابناء المنطقه الواحده نحنا
هذه الفعاليه فعاليه عسكريه عسكريه لكن
قلنا يجب ان تشتمل على داعمي القوات
المسلحه من ابناء الازرق كلهم جميعا هم
داعمين وهم مؤسسين للقوات المسلحه لذلك
راينا انه صاحب معنا ما ضل يؤرق
السودانيين وما ضل يشغلهم في الفتره
السابقه من الاحترام والصراع القبلي الذي
نحسب انه كان سحابه عابره يجب ان تضل
صحابه عابره ويجيب ان نصمم على انها سحابه
عابره يجب ان لا نسمح لهذه الاحداث بان
تتكرر الناظر للخريطه الديموغرافيه في هذه
المنطقه يرى كل السودان موجود هنا كلهم
هذا الكلام ده لاهلنا كلهم
من كل القبائل الموجوده
كلهم كلهم
[موسيقى]
البلد دي بلد السودان السودان ده كلنا
كلنا سنين الطويله دي كلها والمنطقه دي
مملكه قديمه كانت مستوعب الناس كلهم
والناس كلهم كانوا عايشين فيها نحن نحزن
لانه في زمن او في القرن ال 21 او ال 22
تطلع الامور او الكلام اللي احنا تجاوزناه
والعالم تجاوز والشعب السوداني تجاوزوا من
مئات السنين نحن يجب ان نسموا
ونستشرف مستقبل ابناءنا ومستقبل شبابنا
لاننا هذا الولد هذا السودان يسعنا جميعا
نحن كلنا نحترم الاعراف والتقاليد القبليه
القامه عليها السودان نعترف ونحترف انه
هنالك اسس قبليه
مخصصه للاداره هذه الحواكير نحن نقول الله
يرحمه
ويقول والله
ابدا الحفوره دي النظام
الحكومات لفرض سيطره على الناس الموجودين
هو اكيد كله ذوق ممكن يعيش فيها ما في زول
ما لم يحرق العادات واللوائح والنظم
والمجتماعيه بعد ذاك ممكن الناس يجيبوا
يتكلموا معاهم تكلموا معاهم بالقانون
تكلموا معه
بالشيء مرعي برضو نحنا بنفتكر انه هذه
العادات والتقاليد يجب ان لا تخرها يجب
الا نمشي نظم اداريه فوق النظاميه دي كلها
عادات وتقاليد نحن كلنا حافظناها على
السودان الساعه القديمه
[موسيقى]
وصلنا في النهايه لكلمه سواء تجمع اهلنا
نرجو ان نحافظ على هذه الكلمه هيكون عندنا
لقاء اخر نستقبل فيه وهذا الامر نحن هنا
يجب ان نحيي في هذا المقام اخونا مالك
مالك عقاد شكري كبير جدا
هذا الرجل
السياده السوداني عبد الفتاح البرهان في
زيارته ولايه النيل الازرق السودانيه
لحضور مهرجان الرمايه رقم 57 وايضا لحضور
جلسه صلح وتوقيع لوثائق ومعاهدات سلام بين
قبائل متناقره بين مكونات ولايه ثانيه
الازرق وايضا قبيله الهوستا شكرا لكم
مشاهدينا الحسين المتابعه والان الى
العناوين
اذا نهايه هذه النشره المجاهدين في امان
الله
[موسيقى]